thank you
[Music]
welcome back to another amazing episode
of careful boys today we have Mr Steve
Toronto with us
Steve is here we got more Japanese guys
than normal yeah
now we need to have Fox we
zagawa
that's like hella International and
different too because like Hawk is yeah
yeah he checks a lot of boxes
so then uh today let's talk about our
favorite martial arts movie scenes
but they don't and we don't know there's
favorite martial arts movies all right
let's start with kickboxer
which one where he dips in glass
where he gets his gloves and then he
dips it in glass and he dips I thought
that was the craziest [__] when I saw
that as a kid it was pretty crazy you
can get glue and glass and nails and I
was like bro cause at that time I had a
fascination with bats and on like
and then yeah and I would make those
Fascination
I had an Etsy store or whatever
I wanted to be a weapon maker
yeah you know apparently it's illegal I
was a part-time POG player and a weapons
maker
Barbed wires pops but when I saw the
gloves with the glass and I'm like
they're gonna fight with that I was like
whoa I gotta find a way to go to
marketing uh Drunken Master 2 when the
ax gang shows up screw you
remember that when he's eating with the
master at the cafe on the second they
have the giant staff there's a jump
scare when they look out the window it's
all quiet no one's there and then these
guys just pop up and there's 500 dudes
you know my favorite part of that is
mine's also the first one the first
movie those what's your favorite part
part of that scene yes is when he starts
they get the bamboo things yeah and then
they rip their clothes off of course
only because the bamboo stick started
breaking and it was sick
and then they spit on the [__] uh
and then they start [__] everybody
out oh dude
whack people right and then he can open
it and people would punch and he gets
caught up
is because it it looks like a large
version of like the broom you'd get hit
with it
yeah so many different parts of the
environment like Jackie Chan Drunken
Master 2 is like probably one of my
favorite top martial arts movies ever
the first still holds up and the first
time I ever like I think got like fell
in love with the style you know the guy
that wears glasses that goes like yeah
oh yeah oh my God
[Laughter]
he played the perfect little douchebag
yeah he's great isn't he like Jackie
Chan's like but that's what I found out
later that's his actual bodybuild that I
put in the movie that I'm like because
his legs his footwork was like
it's [__] nuts I forgot the name of
the movie but it's another Jackie Chan
movie but he fights anytime he fights
Benny the jet or kiddos oh
my other one that doesn't get mentioned
enough I forgot the [__] name but
it's from the it's from the uh uh the
landlord and Kung Fu Hustle with the
mustache he's in it and he has the cigar
you know remember that yeah what movie
is that I totally forgot that but
they're fighting like a meth lab and
that whole fight scene where uh the guy
with the beard yeah yeah the guy with
the mustache is beating up the girl
which is kind of crazy that's funny but
and then and then uh Jackie Chan and
Benny the jet are fighting that whole
scene where he's kicking him into all
the cardboard boxes in the world the
pace of the choreography you don't see
anything like that just the white shot
to this day you don't see anything yeah
pure talent yeah no editing it's just
wide shot the camera just follows it's
going back and forth Just Dusty as hell
can we also all agree the Kung Fu Hustle
fight with the ring
all movies loaded
there's that one Benny the jet fight
scene too when they're like in a castle
looking place that's Meals on Wheels
right because yeah so why did the way
that they're fight even during that time
would Jack a chance of the black shirt
yeah both of them are tired and they're
like like even the acting within that
yeah like the Beats it's like it's all
story too because he's like adjusting to
everything yeah right right yeah it's so
sick because then he like relaxes yeah
yeah and they didn't do the whole cable
[__] that was an actual like fight scene
like it was like yeah what about all
all-time favorites is Iron Monkey I love
Iron
monkeys right yeah yeah that was like
one of my favorite movies growing up as
a kid flying around on the roof and [__]
yeah yeah dude and he's just flying
around I like the scene in Ip Man where
he [__] up all those Japanese dudes
that's always he goes into that Judo
like that [__] karate thing
and then there you see the Japanese
Imperial Army guy getting like really
like his Eagle hurt while it's happening
and I'm like [__] man I'm conflicted I
love the Japanese guy to win but it's so
good
that's the funniest part though is like
whether it's Bruce Lee or when you watch
a Hong Kong film the bad guys are the
Japanese guys yeah because they're like
the Nazi guys right but it's so funny
because I'm always rooting for the
Chinese and I'm like yeah [__] the
Japanese
they gotcha what if I can come you know
what you know what's amazing my one of
my favorite scenes is in ongbok when
he's in that like fighting ring and he
fights different opponents but the last
guy he fights is just a bar fighter yeah
remember he's just like yeah [__] off
the wall throwing plates and he's not
like a refined martial arts but it's
like the hardest fight because it's so
unpredictable like a refrigerator
yeah
he ran out of [__] to grab he's throwing
AC [__] like like big ass air
conditioning machines dude that is a
dope ass idea dude Bruce Lee in Return
of the Dragon or way of the Dragon
not a lot of people like that movie but
I love it
no return to the dragons when he's in
Rome and he's helping the restaurant is
that when he's in the back alley yeah
and the guy tries to use nunchucks
they're tiny spare ribs bro I love that
part anytime well let me show you yeah
what a good joke too by the way uh I
love that movie I like the um so some of
it is called Chinese connection and the
other one is called um
it's nice Bruce Lee beating up 20
Japanese people oh yeah yeah what was
dope is um he's surrounded and then I
think that was like the first time I got
POV shots of the people getting beat up
because you see a sidekick
and then the camera Cuts you
felt like you're like really really in
it and then they would cut to wives of
how fast and then like a top-down shot
of him like [__] like spin kick care
spin kicking they're like yup oh so sick
so sick what about protector when he
gets up the building oh the one shot or
the one shot where he's breaking
everybody's limbs
I'm surprised he's not doing more movies
now he got tired yeah he's too much the
race the first ombok though blew my mind
crazy yeah
cars and like I was like man these Thai
guys are so fast parkour stuff running
off yeah it was like so many good like
Clips in that it's a really great clips
for ages of my life there were certain
movies that people would be like bro you
gotta watch this movie and you're like
what is this ombok was one of them at
that time because I feel like martial
arts movies are kind of like dead at
that point yeah but that movie kind of
like researched it was aggressive and
fast yeah because the raid came out a
little bit later
he probably had one of the best premises
of why they were fighting yeah yeah the
fact that there's these all these cops
are stuck in a building locked up so
good goddamn and then up is problems
yeah balance problems outside in
soda Rumble the Bronx obviously
obviously but witch fight out of all of
them was your favorite oh dang I don't
know if it's like specifically like I
like the one in the uh the gang house
because he has to go through it yeah
that scene is crazy so so great and then
like uh just because they had so many
things to work with with the pinball
machines and then the ski all the stolen
merch like the fridges with the freaking
gunshot stop stop
and then and then he says his Proverbs
to him
uh martial art movies are more or less
creative the what do you think martial
art movies are more or less creative
nowadays that I I think they're just
different you know they I think like
John Wick has their own style now you
know it's like that's like new age stuff
it's all just like an evolution Rumble
in the Bronx there's a hovercraft and
the only way to take out the hovercraft
is to steal a Lamborghini
I feel like back in the day too people
didn't have a good understanding of like
what can really happen yeah so then you
can go wild but also you had to use
imagination because you didn't have
technology yeah so I thought like even
watching the the the
um Jackie Chan's like when he slides was
it the cop one police story
because he's bringing his hands right
because you could trick that today yeah
yeah and like mission is impossible
style coming down from a building or
whatever but like back then that was
just a dude a dude literally burning the
[__] out of his hands yeah and almost
dying or remember what he jumps from
parking garage to the other like fire
escape
they're crazy and then I catch it with
cardboard
dude and then even the thing was backed
up in the corner and they're using like
glass bottles and hitting it they were
like real glass it was really getting
cut that was exactly really yeah that
was just actually crazy I was like nope
what's that girl's name yeah what's that
girl's name his love interest in that
movie the girl's name in the movie yeah
what was her name Francois or something
yeah I was like you're [__] Nancy in
the movie not the actor yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
oh another one it's a little bit more
new age but it's like Donnie Yen this
movie called Flashpoint I haven't seen
it oh wait yeah yeah dude the fights
because he he Blends MMA and Jiu Jitsu
in these like Hong Kong style martial
arts scenes he fights Colin Chow at the
end and it's such a [__] good fight
this is the one in the alleyway no and I
think that's that's SPO isn't it oh yeah
spo's really good because he fights uh
Samo hung at the end Donnie Yen and Sam
uh Samuel hung is like the man he's a
big dude that can move into the dragon
isn't that crazy his career yeah yeah
Bruce Lee all the way to Donnie wait man
Jackie Chan too wasn't it yeah yeah
he has one nice net Break scene yeah and
a dragon obviously what about um what's
that Jackie Chan's First Strike when he
fights with a ladder yeah that's that's
pretty freaking up there they're just
like freaking trying to jump through the
ladder and like the stuff so low bro
dude oh you know I don't even want to
handle him you guys ever watched like
the old school Wong feijo and stuff like
Jet League oh yeah that might be a super
like that's deep cut it's usually like
only in Chinese though yeah but it's a
lot of like the flying [__] but like uh
there was like crate there's one where
he fights a monster that like so he's
like a a like an evil General that
almost got killed but then some shallow
monks saved them and he turns into like
this weird mushy like like clay creature
yeah and you would roll up in this like
all metal [__] vehicle even though
it's like
Chinese medieval times and his signature
move would be into the people's hearts
and he would just [__] split them in
half and he would just see a straight
shallowing monks just split it out on
the screen what was the name of that one
ah I forgot they're so because that
sounds like some Ricky oh [__] did you
guys ever see that this one where it was
like it was like jelly like jelly jelly
like bodies and then they punch and they
explode there's like I don't even know
what it is
yeah where he's like in a prison and
like yeah yeah yeah he punches and then
the eyes are there but the freaking and
he punches
the clips are pretty much the whole
movie uh because then the rest of it
kind of sucks yeah you gotta wait
through all the time there's a freaking
I want to say it's a Thai movie that I
can't I saw it randomly on a whim and I
can't find it now because I don't
remember the name but it was about like
I think these it might be tired Endo but
these guys they basically get stuck in a
maze and they have to fight all these
different dudes in different rooms and
then at one point he fights like a trans
guy who's like in stockings and heels
and that's like one of the hardest
fights
I wish I'd always tried grapple yeah
yeah and like and then the trans guy
beats up with all these like gay moves
it's freaking dope though it's super
sick but I can't remember the name I
just kind of randomly watch it on
Netflix today and then he took it off oh
man yeah so many good ones I got one
I feel like the that Golden Era of kung
fu and Hong Kong Cinema the Golden
Harvest area
I'm like are there still teams doing
that
I haven't seen any movies that are
everything is like now this realism it's
either that or like Crouching Tiger Old
School drama [__] I think all those guys
with Donnie Yen like whatever is the it
man I see or just because Diane has a
bunch of other movies like Hong Kong
movies that like probably no one in the
states have really heard yeah but like I
feel like it's the same style but it's
just like the newer generation but now
he's doing movies in the states so he's
a main producer I think there's Raymond
Raymond challenge
yeah he's the main Golden Harvest guy so
all everything he touches has that feel
but I don't know if there's new guys
making those kinds of movies is the
thing because like because at last one
was like Kung Fu Hustle yeah which I
feel like that hit all the comedic notes
but also that old school like so good
right so good man comfortable awesome
man it's a masterpiece that movie I
remember I told you guys before there's
a video on YouTube that breaks down all
the cultural references in Kung Fu
Hustle because it's more than what you
think yeah like the reasoning by why
sister certain actors are there
accented Cinema yes they're all based on
like historical Chinese Cinema things
yeah oh so there's like more inside
baseball like is it kind of like how
Tarantino uses these old school like
yeah it's a lot like that like to pay
homage like yeah absolutely okay okay I
absolutely like that kind of like how
the landlord and the landlord landlady
they're like old school Cinema people or
theater people and the Frog guy at the
end like the three of them together they
they create this kind of like uh tribute
to like old Cinema they're kind of
reprising old characters wow yeah it's
like a strange thing I had no idea
but yeah there's a lot of like oh geez
just in that movie alone
like dude oh you know what else is a um
what's a good scene is the Cynthia
Rothrock Michelle
she was badass both of them were
feelings yeah she was so tight but she
kind of she's not making movies too
right since they're Rothrock yeah
she went into like 2000s I think really
yeah but they were like super B movies
yeah like the one with the hook and the
guy's eyes yeah yeah
where the dude like they basically have
a whole fight and then at the end uh the
bad guy gets a hook in his eye like with
a chain and it carries him away so the
whole time
we got those one-liners yeah they got a
one line where he goes uh he goes like
something like see she goes yeah CEO yes
oh yeah it goes keep an eye out for you
Stingray yeah
and then the other guy goes yeah see ya
the whole time
it's so [__] good but that was like a
viral video but the fights in that are
actually really decent she's really good
she's really good on camera have you
guys ever gotten to Samurai westerns
like um Kurosawa films and stuff like
[__] uh
there's a ton Seven Samurai yeah yeah
like oh Seven Samurai is considered a
samurai Western well
that's kind of like the more cinematic
cool [__] right the samurai westerns are
more like actual like western style like
small little Productions it's so you
know how Kong had their Golden Era of
like that kind of film yeah so Japan had
its own like Samurai era of sword
fighting choreograph and story and stuff
it was pretty cool but a lot of the
westerns in America
like modeled their style of showdown
from that from kurosaw films yeah
but I don't think it made that much of a
global like appeal like Hong Kong Kung
Fu flicks but it's more like um it's
older too so yeah so I think the it's
it's kind of like the people that know
they know yeah you know what to go
American too Bloodsport oh man the fight
between him and the guy that looks like
vladi divock and they're keeping each
other yeah he was an actual fighter he
was a real fighter
didn't they tell him that him to like
tone it down because you
yeah they just kept hitting each other
ribs yeah come on dude that's pretty
[__] sick dude hey do you guys ever
watch uh the Rurouni Kenshin
movies
so like one of the previous guys for um
like Donnie Yen like Kenji tanagaki uh
he's like this action designer it
there's you have to look them up because
all these uh Samurai fights they're
shots so crazy good and and usually like
animes
um fights or like live action movies are
kind of like yeah those ones the all
these fights are crazy good
um but yeah live action
uh so it's live action it's live action
right live action but then they the
talent level of uh like the actors they
play homage to to the anime oh perfect
okay and even though it's like over over
the top acting on some of the villains
and and stuff but the fights are crazy
you get all all the uh story beats and
all these crazy like cut Cuts in it that
make it like not lame in a way that you
would think this is the one that Joey T
is in is it no that uh Joyce was in
um our friend was in uh enter the fat
dragon oh I know that one's sick he
wasn't in kitchen I thought he played a
character oh did he I don't know I'm not
sure you see that enter the fat dragon
you see this one so our friend our
friend goes casually he just goes oh I'm
in that movie and we go really he didn't
tell us he's a [__] main bad guy yeah
that's [__] sick yeah so we watched
him we're like you're the you're the
last fight you idiot why are you so
humble you're the guy
he's a villain what about the
live-action Dragon Ball Z movie do you
guys like that one yeah yeah it's my one
of my favorites I only like the [__]
fighting scene where he keeps sliding
[Laughter]
yeah it's ridiculous
I hope the Airbender live action movie
has really good fights
who's doing flopped right the one that
they was this Shyamalan did it yeah yeah
who's doing it who's doing the new one
I don't know I know it's a series though
oh it's a series yeah on Netflix it'll
probably be better wow oh yeah it would
have to be serious man the story's too
long yeah how do you tell them when in
one movie it's weird
laughs